the mayor of oakland taking a swipe at
las vegas this morning mayor libby
schaff was talking about the oakland a's
baseball stadium project something on
the table for years the delay has led
the team to explore other options
including las vegas today mayor chef
praised her city and the idea of a
waterfront stadium then took a shot at
our city referring to it as quote gross
desert
now as you can imagine many of us who
call the so-called gross desert home
have not taken kindly to her words a lot
of comments coming in on twitter first
hearing from mayor carolyn goodman
calling this city a world leader in
sustainability and a top destination she
invited oakland's mayor to a raiders
game here remember the raiders jumped
ship in oakland also bringing in some
comments from viewers we hear from
locals vegas and its gross desert is
revered worldwide and we don't need
artists renderings to show off our
beautiful town let's go to one more this
one says you want to unify the people of
las vegas call our city gross